let's understand another example on a
new page assume you have three red
marbles and three blue marbles in a box
your task is to pull out two marbles out
of these six marbles one after the other
this example is interesting but I need
you to focus really really hard so there
will be two cases here first case you
pick the first marble out and then put
it back and then take the second marble
out you take one out put it back in and
then pick the second marble let's talk
about this case first say we want to
find the probability of getting a red
marble out in your first chance let's
call it P of r1 there are three red
marbles and six marbles in all so the
probability of getting a red marble is
three by six the numerator tells us that
we can pick a red marble in three ways
and the denominator tells us the total
number of marbles so you picked one red
marble up and placed it back in now what
is the probability of picking a red
marble in your second charge we call it
P of R 2 since we place the ball back in
there are three red marbles and six
total marbles so the probability still
remains three by six
it's unchanged so these two events are
called independent events the
probability does not change if the
marble is replaced it's because we have
the same set of marbles we had
originally now let's look at the second
case you pick one marble out and then
pick the second one out without putting
it back in now it gets even more
interesting focus hard in this case we
pick one marble we do not put it back in
and then we pick a second marble now
let's find the probability of picking a
red marble in your first chance it will
be three by six you can pick a red
marble in three ways out of the six
possible marbles so assume the red
marble is taken out but remember this
time it's not put back in the box it
remains outside now what is the
probability of picking a red marble
there are two red marbles and five in
total so the probability of picking a
red marble is two by five did you
observe what happened we can see that
the probability has changed if the
marble is not replaced so in this case
the events are not independent now
forget the color of the marbles you
should know that if a marble is put back
in then the events will be independent
as the sample space does not change for
the second case but if the marble is not
put back in then the sample space
changes for the second event which is
why the events are not independent the
probability of second event actually
depends on what marble you have picked
first we will understand what mutually
exclusive means in our next video
you